Tim Burton has had plenty of hit films
over the years many of which have gone
on to become classics but as with any
filmmaker he's also had some misses too
from vampire clicks and lackluster
remakes to biopics and modern-day fairy
tales here are Tim Burton's films ranked
from worst to best adapting a beloved
television show into film is usually a
pretty big risk
and unfortunately for Burton taking on
this particular 1960 series didn't work
out very well in 2012 Burton took on
Dark Shadows which was based on a gothic
soap opera that originally aired from
1966 to 1971
Dark Shadows tells the story of Johnny
Depp's Barnabas Collins an ancient and
immortal vampire who attempts to
assimilate into 20th century society
Burton has worked with Depp many many
times but Dark Shadows is easily one of
their least successful collaborations
the film garnered terrible reviews and
despite benefiting from Burton's
signature cinematic flourishes depths
silly performance and the insanely
outlandish plot really dragged a movie
down
Dark Shadows probably seemed like the
perfect adaptation for Burton but in the
end it proved one of his weakest efforts
to date the final shot in the original
Planet of the Apes is one of the most
iconic scenes in film history and in
2001 Burton made the daring choice to
helm a remake of this classic movie with
Mark Wahlberg taking on Heston's role
Burton crafted a relatively loose
adaptation of the original for an
astronaut named Leo Davidson lands on an
entirely new planet inhabited by Apes
and tries to overthrow their tyrannical
rule despite the film's otherwise
Sterling cast it performed poorly with
critics and won multiple Golden
Raspberry Awards thanks to a terrible
lead performance by Wahlberg and a weird
bizarrely confusing ending even though
it performed well at the box office
Burton said he would rather jump out a
window than direct a sequel due in large
part to the overbearing studio
interference he endured on the project
Fox parents studio of the film didn't
pursue the option either simply
rebooting the entire franchise 10 years
later with 2011 s Rise of the Planet of
the Apes
as far as classic Disney films go Dumbo
is still a firm fan favorite and in 2019
Burton helmed a live-action remake of
the original 19
one film the movie tells the story of
Dumbo from a human perspective focusing
on a world war one amputee who takes on
a job as an animal caretaker for a
traveling circus where his main
responsibility is caring for a pregnant
elephants who eventually gives birth to
a baby with extraordinarily large ears
but this classic tale didn't seem to
translate with live-action cast and it
fared poorly with critics and at the box
office the overall critical conclusion
was that the film failed to capture the
magic of the original thanks in part to
an unnecessarily expanded story which
isn't hugely welcomed in a film nobody
was clamoring for in the first place
Lewis Carroll's classic novels Alice's
Adventures in Wonderland and through the
looking-glass have inspired generations
of artists and readers alike since their
initial releases in 1865 and 1871 and
considering the Burton has always
gravitated towards dark and fantastical
stories it's probably not surprising
that he chose to adapt Carroll's
signature work in 2010 but even though
Alice in Wonderland seemed like the
ideal project for a filmmaker like
Burton the movie just didn't land
despite a star-studded cast and Burton's
typical stylistic flair the film earned
mediocre reviews thanks to its subpar
CGI effects a number of bizarre changes
to Carol's story and Depp's
cringe-worthy dance number at the end of
the film
[Music]
however this didn't stop Burton from
carrying on his Carole inspired
narrative in 2016 he produced Alice
Through the Looking Glass which saw the
original cast reprised their roles let's
just say that film didn't fare
particularly well with critics either
with Mars Attacks Burton took the
potentially risky decision to base a
film on a popular trading card game and
well it didn't really work out the campy
story finds the residents of Earth and
Mars meeting officially for the first
time though things go sour pretty
quickly and ultimately the humans must
find a way to defeat the Martians upon
its initial release the film received
fairly lukewarm reviews but in the end
pacing issues a squandered cast a
concept that seemed great on paper but
doesn't work in the final execution
makes this one of Burton's less
successful outings however in the year
since its debut it's become a cult
classic proving the Burton's instincts
were certainly right for certain
audiences in 2016
Burton adapted the popular children's
novel miss Peregrine's Home for peculiar
children which thanks to it's
supernatural bent in an emotional core
must have been right up his alley the
film focuses on a home run by miss
Peregrine's that houses paranormally
gifted children and helps to hone their
abilities as best as possible miss
Peregrine's and her children hide
themselves in a time loop that she
created allowing them to evade unwanted
and negative attention but as they mess
with time more and more the children at
miss Peregrine's wind up separated
critics didn't exactly love the
narrative of miss Peregrine's but still
praised Burton's visual stylings and
ultimately the film earned decent
reviews in the end using a children's
novel rather than an original concept
failed Burton here as the story itself
just isn't gripping enough to rank among
the directors stronger efforts resulting
in a fairly forgettable film almost
everyone will be familiar with Roald
Dahl's classic novel Charlie and the
Chocolate Factory not least because it's
been adapted a fair few times over the
years in 2005 Burton and Johnny Depp
took on this cherished tale with depth
as Willy Wonka alongside his Finding
Neverland co-star Freddie Highmore one
of Burton's crucial additions to this
film came in the form of Wilbur Wonka
Willy Wonka's father which the director
felt gave new dimension to a well-known
character and while critics enjoyed
burdens
in depth look at Willie Wonka as far as
fans of the original are concerned it's
pretty much impossible to replace Gene
Wilder's iconic original performance
sadly Depp's porkier go at the roll
indeed felt off-kilter
next to Wilders portrayal by adding new
songs mixing up the narrative and
providing Wonka with a full backstory
Burton missed a mark on what made dolls
book and the wilder film so popular in
the first place consequently as the
years have gone by audiences have
largely forgotten Burton's take on Wonka
in 1984 during his tenure at Disney
Burton crafted a short film called
Frankenweenie a clever retelling of the
classic Frankenstein story about a boy's
beloved dog who was brought back to life
only to be hunted down by the boys
terrified neighbors Disney ended up
firing Burton after he presented them
with a film since they believed it was
hugely unsuitable for children but in
2012 he returned to the project and made
it into a feature-length animated film
ironically Disney ended up producing the
movie which proved to be both a critical
and commercial success for the director
and studio alike earning over 81 million
dollars at the worldwide box office the
film thrilled critics and audiences and
even scored nominations at the Academy
Awards and Golden Globes it also holds
the distinction of becoming the first
black and white film and the first
stop-motion film to be released in IMAX
3d Tim Burton doesn't usually go for
biopics or historical dramas but with
2014's big eyes he made a film that set
firmly in both categories telling the
true story of artist Margaret Keane big
eyes is a stylistic yet harrowing
portrait of a woman who's overshadowed
by her less talented husband Walter
starring Amy Adams and Christoph Waltz
as Margaret and Walter the film ended up
doing pretty well critically much of
praise heaped on the film came largely
to atoms and Walt's two performers at
the top of their craft
Burton's fantastical colorful visuals
didn't exactly hurt either
by handling Margaret Keens struggles
with empathy and care the film presents
a rare glimpse into this artists
well-known work even though she went
without credit for years thanks to her
conniving husband it was also a rare
award season favourite for Burton
earning a Golden Globe for atoms and a
nomination for Walt's
based on a 1998 novel by Daniel Wallace
Burton's 2003 adaptation of big fish
became one of his signature films and
thanks to its fantastical imagery
whimsical premise and extraordinarily
sharp script and performances it's easy
to see why the film follows the fanciful
and imaginative life stories of a
traveling salesman named Edward bloom
told to his son while Edward is on his
deathbed Burton was drawn to the project
thanks to his own strained relationship
with his parents both of whom he lost in
the early 2000s as such he wanted to
help tell an intimate story of a parent
and child's reconciliation before the
former's passing all told big fish is
still one of Burton's most beloved
movies likely due to the young Ewan
McGregor's anchoring performance and the
visual feast that the film offers up
which strikes an incredible contrast to
the grounded story that's instantly
relatable to anybody with family issues
of their own
despite Burton's occasional misses the
director is clearly well suited for the
horror genre and he made that very clear
in 1999's
Sleepy Hollow very loosely based on the
classic Washington Irving short story
the film follows Ichabod Crane a police
constable sent to investigate the
haunting of the titular small village by
the mysterious ghost of the Headless
Horseman a perfect film for any
Halloween season Sleepy Hollow presents
an extraordinarily strange but
ultimately successful take on Irving's
original tale adding in a few extra
elements including a new twist on the
Horseman's role in the story Burton had
already made his mark in film making by
1999 but this movie definitely proved
that when it came to classic horror he
was capable of doing things no other
director could featuring vocal
performances by Burton regulars Johnny
Depp and Helena Bonham Carter the
touching stop-motion film corpse bride
tells the tale of two chiller bride
Emily who inadvertently marries a
nervous human man Victor just before his
actual wedding to another human named
Victoria as Victor and Emily take an
unexpected journey through the realms of
the living and the dead things begin to
get complicated and more than a little
bit creepy to thanks to the imaginative
animation and the emotional story corpse
bride garnered hugely positive reviews
and although it harkens back to the
Otherworld
the Burton produced The Nightmare Before
Christmas corpse bride succeeds by
utilizing an entirely new plot that
bears all of Burton's signature touches
and flourishes between the
groundbreaking animation techniques
bittersweet story and exceptionally
beautiful visuals corpse bride quickly
became one of Burton's most well-loved
films based on the classic musical by
Stephen Sondheim sweetie Todd tells the
gripping and bloody story of a vengeful
barber named Sweeney Todd who returns to
London to avenge the loss of his wife
and daughter at the hands of a corrupt
judge the cast features plenty of Burton
regulars as well as a few standout
newcomers like Sasha Baron Cohen
Sondheim himself enjoyed the adaptation
and it performed well enough critically
plus casting choices like Baron Cohen
Alan Rickman and Helena Bonham Carter
paired perfectly with Burton's more
McCobb sensibilities clearly the Golden
Globes agreed considering the film was
nominated for several awards at the 2008
ceremony nabbing Best Motion Picture
Musical or Comedy as well as an award
for Depp's performances Todd after the
monumental success of Burton's first
Batman film it makes sense that he
agreed to come back for a sequel so in
1992 both him and Michael Keaton
returned for well Batman Returns in this
installment Danny DeVito Michelle
Pfeiffer and Christopher Walken play a
trio of grotesque villains
the penguin Catwoman and conniving
executive Max Schreck the film was
actually a struggle for Burton to get
produced burden and Keaton only agreed
to a comeback after Keaton got a
significant raise and burden was assured
that it wouldn't have to be too much of
a sequel to the first movie in the end
Batman's return marked a darker deeper
take on the Caped Crusader and gave the
world a genre defining performance from
Pfeiffer as the seductive psychotic
Catwoman
sadly Burton and Keaton both passed on
the third film leaving the world with
this what killed the dinosaurs for
Burton's feature film debut as a
director he took on the beloved
children's character of pee-wee Herman
after Paul Reubens TV show about peewee
proved to be a huge success a
full-length movie was an inevitability
and Rubens himself wrote the script
alongside comedy
Phil Hartman known for his work on the
Simpsons and Saturday Night Live using a
book about script writing his guide
Reubens crafted a tight script for his
project as he later told a crowd during
a panel at South by Southwest it's a
90-minute film it's a 90 page script on
page 30 I lose my bike on page 60 I find
it it's literally exactly what they said
to do in the book Burton was more than
ready to prove himself and helped along
by Reubens considerable talents he
certainly did critics adored the movies
whimsical attitude and the continuity
behind Reubens signature character and
helped along by a number of clever jokes
the film just ends up working from
beginning to end as a director Burton
was clearly off to a great start
Gotham's Dark Knight has been rebooted a
countless number of times since he made
his comic book premiere in 1939 but the
Caped Crusader made his official Warner
Brothers film debut in 1989 with Tim
Burton along as director Batman is
widely regarded as one of the best
Batman movies ever made and the genesis
of the modern superhero movie meaning
you've partially got Burton to thank for
those comic-book movies Marvel and DC
are releasing every 7 hours with Michael
Keaton in the titular role alongside
Jack Nicholson's thrilling turn as the
Joker the film was a critical and
commercial success earning over 400
million dollars total worldwide and it
was the highest-grossing DC comic book
film until its successor The Dark Knight
knocked it off its pedestal in 2008
thanks to a winning cast in Burton's
sharp direction the film was universally
lauded by critics and fans alike those
fans were particularly thrilled to see a
gritty dark superhero story brought to
the big screen and one that ended up
changing the genre for years to come the
other secret to the film's success was
undoubtedly Nicholson's performance as
the Joker
his performance had a new standard of
villainy for generations of Joker's
inspiring everyone from Heath Ledger to
Joaquin Phoenix and it's still widely
regarded as one of the movies ultimate
highlights
[Music]
surprisingly enough one of Burton's best
films is one of his most grounded and
realistic projects to date a biopic of
filmmaker Ed Wood who is famous for
making cult films 1994 is Ed Wood stars
Johnny Depp as the titular director and
focuses on a period of Woods life where
he befriended the actor Bela Lugosi
critics loved the film in large part due
to Depp and Martin Landau stunning
performances the gorgeous cinematography
a number of perfect one-liners and
Burton's straightforward yet creative
approach to the biopic to be sure Ed
Wood is an unusual movie that nobody
knew they needed but it's cemented
itself as one of the directors most
important in well-regarded films
thanks to Burton's incredibly earnest
approach in his biography of wood who is
regarded as one of the worst directors
in history he conversely managed to
cement a legacy for himself as a great
one
Burton's comedy horror classic feel
juice has been a cult favorite since its
release back in 1988 and with good
reason as Burton's breakout film it
tells the terrifyingly yet hilarious
story of a young undead couple who end
up haunting their former home and trying
their best torment its new human
inhabitants unfortunately they're also
accompanied by a particularly irritating
poltergeist named beetlejuice but
critics fell in love with the film long
before it became a cult classic those
critics lavished praise on the movie
which also marks the first-ever
collaboration between Keaton and Burton
led by Keaton's delightfully bombastic
yet carefully crafted performances
Beetlejuice in Cho dad
the film allowed Burton's spookier
sensibilities to play off freely
resulting in a movie that still holds up
as a classic today in the aftermath of
its theatrical debut it ended up winning
an Academy Award for Best makeup and
even spawned a few spin-offs including a
handful of video games and even a
Broadway musical when people think of
Tim Burton it's likely their minds will
go right to Edward Scissorhands and
honestly it's pretty easy to see why
released in 1990 this signature Burton
film tells the incredible and tragic
tale of a manufactured human named
Edward who remains unfinished with crude
scissors serving as his hands when he
wanders out of his home he finds
sanctuary with the suburban Boggs family
with the help of this new family Edward
does his best to fit in but soon
discovers that society has never been
kind outcasts and weirdos thanks to its
fantastical imagery a superb performance
by Depp and a wide array of
larger-than-life set pieces Edward
Scissorhands remains the one movie the
best displays Burton's signature style
and unparalleled directional flourish
suitably enough it's also a favorite of
Burton's - with the director admitting
in the past that it was the most
personal film he had ever made check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]